on va parler de lygia bhl de running
comprenez vous la polémique
et oui de nombreuses polémiques
politiques ont réagi aujourd'hui sur les
chaînes info certain paul appell même un
boycott de la marque puisque il ya une
marque qui a indiqué qu'il allait mettre
en place la commercialisation en france
d'un hidjab de running on vous fait un
petit rappel des faits et juste après
avant de marteler oui voudrais juste
dire que c'est un truc qui m'a touché
vraiment et je pense que les femmes
doivent être libres de choisir ce
qu'elles veulent porter si elles veulent
faire du sport un confit jabel le fonds
affiche m et c'est une polémique qui n'a
pas lieu d'être et je voulais dire avant
de partir de cette mer si malick merci
de le dire le récap et manivelle talent
et sa belle et ron dennis olliech coupe
de marque aussi les bars regardez c'est
une polémique qui agite la classe
politique et les réseaux sociaux tout
commence avec la découverte par le site
al kanz de la mise en ligne par la
marque de sport décathlon d'un hidjab
adaptés aux femmes musulmanes souhaitant
faire du sport un hidjab est un voile
couvrant les cheveux les oreilles et le
cou très vite les réactions affluent
notamment de la part de responsables
politiques à l'image de lydia guirous
porte-parole des républicains décathlon
se soumet également à l'islamisme qui ne
tolère les femmes que la tête couverte
par les ja pour affirmer leur
appartenance à la oumma et leurs
solutions aux hommes décathlon renie
donc les valeurs de notre civilisation
sur l'autel du marché du marketing
communautaire
à gauche on s'insurge également comme la
députée ps valérie rabault qui propose
tout bonnement le boycott de la marque
by côté décathlon en france le boycott
de décathlon c'est également ce que
propose nicolas dupont aignan j'ai deux
filles et je n'ai pas envie qu'elles
vivent dans un pays où la place des
femmes dans la société régresse comme en
arabie saoudite j'appelle au boycott de
la marque décathlon qui commercialise ce
type de vêtement si dans un premier
temps la marque a dénoncé une erreur
technique expliquant que cet article
était destinée au marché marocain et
qu'il n'aurait jamais dû se retrouver
sur la version française du site
aujourd'hui décathlon semble avoir
changé d'aix de défense sa vie rivoire
porte parole de la marque fait marche
arrière et explique qu'il ne s'agit plus
d'une erreur
or mais bien d'une volonté de permettre
à toutes les femmes de faire du sport
une polémique que les community managers
de la marque ont tenté en vain de calmer
face aux centaines de messages à
l'encontre de la commercialisation de ce
produit
alors comprenez vous la polémique alors
comprenez vous la polémique nicolas
dupont aignan nous a rejoint député de
l'essonne et président de debout la
france vous êtes fermement opposé à la
décision de décathlon de vendre un
hidjab de running alors j'ai envie de
vous poser la question que voilà qui va
poser jean pierre carraz de quoi je me
mêle nicolas du queens à new bell tout
simplement j'ai deux filles
oui et j'ai pas envie qu'elle vit dans
cette société là et je vais vous dire il
ya tellement de pays où des femmes sont
en prison sont battus en indonésie en
iran parce qu'elles veulent
ôter le voile et nous dans une
régression complètement dingue on va
alimenter un système de soumission si
c'est leur choix mais liberté égalité
fraternité on n'a pas le droit de primer
la moitié de l'humanité alors que les
femmes c'est comme la moitié de
l'humanité on va accepter par lâcheté au
nom d'une fausse liberté
on va accepter ça mais moi je demande
aux femmes qui sont ici est ce qu'elles
ont envie petit à petit et que ça
commence comme il s'en vend pas entravé
par cette décision
en tant que femme si moi j'ai envie de
courir avec les cheveux à l'air je vois
pas pourquoi y en a qui n'auraient pas
cette possibilité la knu courir ce que
j'aime dans le sport c'est le côté
universalisme et qu'il n'y ait pas de
racisme qu'on ne connaît pas les femmes
d'un côté les hommes de l'autre et à
partir de ce moment là pourquoi pas ces
femmes ont au moins accès aux baraques
tenant voudriez quoi l'ex-stéphanois
reste à l'intérieur de chez elles parce
qu'elles veulent pas aller vous vous
avez la capacité de vous défendre
mais l'effet nazis mais c'est pas vrai
et babx femme aussi mais si je peux me
permettre
oui j'ai lu de banlieue combien de fois
j'ai eu dans mes permanences des femmes
qui ont quitté leur foyer c'est été
battu parce qu'elle refusait de porter
le voile et ya des biens qui n'ont pas
le voit le 6 mai bien évidemment mais
pour autant alité ce qu'ont à tafas
liberté égalité vous trouvez que c'est
normal égalité l'égalité et au est passé
d'ailleurs tient votre copine marlène
schiappa c'est la seul homme c'est la
seule femme politique
la copine d'alors nadal est plaisante et
cyril hanouna
je vous propose un hashtag ou et marlène
schiappa mini ses droits des femmes
oui elle fait ce qu'elle veut et femmes
politiques mais parce que on réagit
aujourd'hui de tous les bords politiques
n'ont pas socialiste tous les bords
politiques l'ont dit danger je pense
qu'un danger parce qu'elle va réagir
alors j'espère avant le sommet et à
regarder moi la réponse de décathlon moi
je les trouvais bonne la réponse de
décathlon je suis désolé des bouchons
rassurez-vous le renault aucune de nos
valeurs nous avons toujours tout fait
pour rendre la pratique du sport plus
accessible partout dans le monde
celui jam était a besoin de certaines
pratiques en deux courses à pied et nous
répondons donc à ce besoin sportif
qu'est ce qu'elle est passé chez les
caps l'ont je vais vous dire ils ont eu
beaucoup de demandes hip hop fait
nicolas dumontheuil ont joué beaucoup de
demandes de fans qui disent voilà moi je
pratique la course à pied et ça serait
ça serait bien de faire ainsi un hidjab
pour avoir un pur pour qu'on puisse
faire du sport et met ses déviations ils
ont répondu à cette demande
derrière tout leur tombe dessus et
renonce ce soir un délire non ce soir
une ironie heureusement à ce que parce
qu'il ya un brillant ird encore qui vit
et qui défend une certaine idée de la
république de la laïcité qui a plein de
fabergé égalité fraternité des massages
peuvent pas aller courir alors qu'on les
aide pas m'enlever loire je comprends
que certains se posent la question donc
je comprends la polémique je comprend
effectivement que certains s'interrogent
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on parle du
voile
on parle de la liberté de la femme le
fait-elle consciemment et en toute
liberté ou ne le fait-elle pas
consciemment ou en toute liberté en
toute liberté
en l'occurrence ce qui me gêne dans
votre discours c'est d'imaginer qu'à
chaque fois qu'une femme porte le voile
c'est parce qu'elle est comprimé et
qu'elle est contraint de sa mère voilà
or il ya autant de femmes voilées que
d'histoires personnelles et donc elles
peuvent le choisiront ne pas le choisir
si je peux me permettre vous avez la
possibilité de dire non mais dans
quantité de fois vous avez une véritable
pression est d'ailleurs jugée j'ai lu
avant de venir
ce magnifique livre de jeannette bougrab
l'aide aux femmes voilées à ceux qui les
soutiennent
je peux vous dire c'est extraordinaire
lisez ça et vous comprendrez ce que je
veux dire
m6 cède là c'est fini ça sera mais le
vous vous passerez toute la mécanique
jeudi pour se rendre compte de certaines
femmes et we came ils ont demandé à la
marque mais oui mais peut-être mais on
est en france on n'est pas
arabie séoudite ou dans un autre pays
même en algérie même en algérie la en
2018 et viennent d'interdire le voile
mais inhibant les i à l'arrivée à leur
accorder
j'aimerais j'aimerais avoir l'avis
greymouth et de rallye les valeurs comme
en abandonnant et où je serais mort est
pour vous et moi je moi je leur mette
pas choqué par le reste je suis pas
choqué je le respecte beaucoup mais il
mélange tout monsieur dupont-aignan vous
mélangez pas ce que vous je prends vos
mots oppressé vous pensez vraiment
qu'une femme oppressés par un mari
extremis est allé corriger que vous les
voyez pas ce qui manque son mari va lui
dire mais bien aux prêts s'est fait à
manger d'abord va faire un footing et
bien ce n'est jamais de la vie
si elle est oppressé il va pas l'envoyer
courir dans un parc avec les gens diallo
près ça ne court pas c'est pas un voile
c'est un tissu
c'est un tissu qui a été commercialisé
par une autre marque à virgule ça n'a
rien à voir vous dit mes enfants je veux
pas qu'ils courent on vante vous a pas
demandé de courir derrière cette femme
laissée là courir avec son boîtier vous
courrez barre son voile décathlon c310
magasins dans toute la france bien
évidemment peut-être il ya des endroit
en france où ils en vendront pas si ce
qui sait comme cyril le dis il ya une
demande il est alors de ça me fait
penser
après jouer après je vous laisse
répondre ça me fait penser qu'il ya 10
ans 15 ans dans les rayons je parlais
avec des gens qu'ils ont mis le halal
dans les rayons on est mort on va tous
manger halal mais non il ya deux rayons
ou à une allée à la halle et tout le
reste du magasin
tu veux manger du saucisson tu manges us
aussi sans rien à tu veux manger casher
tu manges m mais bien sûr que si vous
êtes dans un monde n'a rien avoué peur
d'un roi dites-moi répondait pas tout
dire très clairement quand vous voyez
des gamines de 7 ans qui sont voilées
est ce qu'elles ont la libre la liberté
de dire non en train de parler à temps
des gars qui courent oui mais je
m'attends je vous rassure les lois de la
république l'école et je vais vous les
viols le voile à l'école quand il ya eu
le débat à l'école quand on a interdit
le voile à l'école
il ya eu exactement la même polémique
tout le monde nous est tombé dessus en
nous disant faut pas interdire si les
parents veulent que leurs enfants
portent le voile à l'école nous à les
empêcher des petites jeunes filles de
venir à l'école
eh bien je vais vous dire celles qui ont
été contente le plus souvent ce sont les
petites filles ou les enfants qui
risquait d'être voilées et qui ont dit
merci à la république nous avons un
projet bon et merci à la même sujet
monsieur l'arrivée
c'est l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes et le voir sur la vidéo sans
pareil si vous les armes à castres voile
c'est pas innocent c'est un show de
soumission de la femme agent à cannes où
il savait très bien ce qui me dérange
fait pourquoi je la comprends la
politique parce qu'une fois de plus à
cause de cette polémique
on va encore faire une opposer les gens
là contre ça qui me dérange
effectivement excusez moi je connais un
peu la loi
rien n'interdit dans la mode avec cet
objet c'est un choix que je respecte
en revanche moi ce que je regrette c'est
ce qui m'embête par rapport à la
polémique s'est encore une fois parce
que vos discours quoi que vous en disiez
on va encore dire on va encore mélangé
une fan et les musulmans et moi ça me
dérange beaucoup de musulmans qui valut
à deux voiles je vais le nazillon ni g10
à la nation j'en ai assez en 2019 qu'on
continue encore à alimenter un discours
quoi que vous en disiez qui va une fois
de celle inverse alimenter le racisme et
ses adhérents joies et ses fils et moi
je vais répondre
vous comprenez la polémique puisque
marcos oui je la comprends pas ce qu'ils
veulent et qui répondent à comprendre et
je la regrette pour ça que je la
comprends bien je vais vous répondre
éponger ma suppléante
elle est musulmane va supprimer des
députés elle est d'origine kabyle les
fameux château et un instant elle a été
obligée de déménager à vigneux parce
qu'il voulait on l'a menacée parce que
ses fils n'étaient pas voilées
voilà c'est ça et je peux vous dire que
les français musulmans qui pratiquent
leur foi très bien qu'ils veulent vivre
librement qui eux vont à la mosquée et
qui n'ont rien à voir avec des
salafistes qui sont en train de
gangrener le pays et à chaque concert
[Musique]
c'est la pratique et cercle acheter moi
je vous le dit c'est terrible j'aimerais
que ça commence par le voile sakineh par
la charia
gilbert dassieu poussée du lait ça la
réalité en lave des lisez le livre
s'arrête vous l'idéologie pouvais je
gardais c'est de l'idéologie non c'est
laisser mon seigneur je vous ai de la
discrimination car c'est la meilleure et
pour l'enfant de la rétivité 50%
moi je connais plein de jeunes femmes
musulmanes qui ont envie de courir et
qui a envie de courir voilée comme l ont
emmené connaissez le drame et bien sûr
que j'en connais monsieur vous n'avez
moi je connais plein de femmes
musulmanes jeune musulmane il se bat
pour éviter de voir exactement voit
aussi en banlieue gens que vous
connaissez et bat pour éviter d'avoir
les empêcher de courir et je reconnais
pleinement maison qui a enlevé le voit
et c'est dafniah sérieux roseraie au
dessus du poignet ou joue le voile car
simon il autorise en l'expression libre
cirill ses voiles avait autorisé j'ai
laissé bien entendu série l égalité mais
ce que vous ne comprenez pas à les
empêcher des jeunes femmes musulmanes de
courage tu as choisi permettre c'est
qu'en interdisant ça on permettra d
jeune femme d'enlever leur voile comme
on a permis à des jeunes filles à
l'école
forte de ne pas être obligé de porter la
on les libère cyril et vous mettez le
doigt dans un engrenage terrible
terrible pour les jeunes femmes
gilles en nombreux quartiers ne peuvent
plus sortir sans être voilées joseph est
passé en algérie ça j'y ai passé dans ce
jeu du royaume gil j ai évidemment tu as
raison il ya évidemment de nombreuses
femmes qui ont décidé de court équipe
ont créé une courir parce qu'elle vous
aurez la possibilité d'avoir un hidjab
gens tiennent la corde ici mais c'est
pas forcément de la soumission et la
certaine mais je travaillais qu'au nom
des femmes qui à cause de cette
commercialisation devront le porter je
ne sais pas quel sera le pourcentage de
ces femmes 1 rien qu'au nom de cette
pension pourtant sage ce pourcentage de
femmes ont devraient s'insurger il est
trop tard vous allez avoir le burqini
bientôt sur les plats en a déjà eu la
sangre heureusement c'était bloqué sur
l'essai donnait plus faible que si vous
avez été c'est l'honneur de notre esprit
cela même si je comprends la polémique
et 700 et rians de droit parce
qu'effectivement c'est légal ça soulève
des questions qui sont sous jacente dans
la société
trail et qui reviennent régulièrement
par le burqini par le voile par ça et
moi ce qui me gêne dans le fait que
décathlon est après nike après d'autres
marques est mis justement alors ça
prendra
c'est vrai après plusieurs marques
celles
de d'encourager la promotion de la
religion dans le sport alors comme moi
le sport c'est la liberté mais c'est
tout cela dit juste libéré dit oui
décathlon la liberté ce cas l'agent
voulu faire là-bas la wii mais est
d'ailleurs lors leurs tweets le montre
bien
a décathlon n'avoir eu de crs mais face
à la polémique c'est oui ça a été ça
peut être maladroit mais décathlon en
fait au départ c'était pour faire du
fric et des jeux olympiques on dira de
lui les athlètes sont voilées d'arabie
saoudite du bahreïn de les critiquer et
oui mais aussi et alors que les femmes
françaises vivre comme l'arabie saudite
nema du coup je vous dis juste comme et
grâce à ça l oms qui s'active et aux
jeux olympiques et elles ont pu se
dépêtrer de jeu venir expliquer ce que
je voudrais c'est qu'on a un an mais
qu'elles peuvent enlever le voile et on
a une responsabilité de les libérer mais
vous imaginez le nombre de femmes en
iran qui aujourd'hui se libère du voile
pour lutter contre le régime des mollahs
faisait je vais vous envoyer un signal
que la république française qu'est le
lieu de l'égalité des sexes accepte a
soumis la liberté de lescar âges vous
savez voudra pas les esclavagistes au
19e siècle qui voulait pas supprimer l'
esclavage et qu'ils aient la liberté
mais au nom quand même de la république
on a le droit à un moment de dire stop à
l'asservissement nommé juste parce que
sinon c'est ça christine kelly a promis
sans plus pour ses téléspectateurs après
au moins qu un curseur c'est que par
exemple la publicité pour ce niqab
serait pas possible pour moi c'est un
curseur alors la publicité moi je moi je
pense qu'ils ont fait ça au nom de la
liberté
alors oui et que voilà il ya des jeunes
femmes voilà qui avait demandé ce
produit l épave enlever leur voile à
leur demande ils ont pu courir sans
voile comprenez-vous la polémique sur
les gardes de running 42% oui nous à 58%
quand même moi je trouve personnellement
que ça a été beaucoup de bruit encore
mais je veux dire elle a aidé nicolas
dupont thierry lannes una je peux vous
dire une chose avait été utile parce
qu'ils ont renoncé à nouveau baisser la
pression populaire monde en a marre
mais pourquoi vous enseignez jamais le
jour 2 5 il ya plein de saoudiens il ya
plein d'égyptiens il ya plein de
libanais ils ont dévoilé hermès chanel
dior les poids vous n'allez pas vous
allez changer qu'on m'a redonné moi vous
faites pas à l'aise entend pas quand
c'est les puissants ils se lassent et
l'airé les besoins aux gens qui vont à
des cartons ont laissé les gens
tranquilles à la rd4 monde décathlon
c'est bien parce que moi j'achète tout
là bas il ya la marque et ça que je suis
à il ya tout kalenji csu peut faire des
enquêtes
[Rires]
voilà du plaignant d'avoir été là merci
d'avoir été là en tout cas d'avoir
répondu merci à vous d'avoir des battues
en tout cas dans cette émission